We've talked before about the amount of projection
in American politics and particularly among the
American right wing. If they are accusing someone
of something, they are almost certainly doing it
themselves. In a Fox News segment that is beyond
satire, Trump in Republican Congresswoman Lauren
Bobert says Democrats are obsessed with conspiracy
theories. Check this out. Here she is on Judge
Jeanine Pirro Show saying that no one on the
outside can get into the capital only because
of these conspiracy theories that Democrats are
obsessed with, which has led to National Guard
troops. But, you know, I remember something
happening on January 6th that explains why the
National Guard troops are there. I think there's
real questions about how long are they staying.
But I seem to remember something happening there
on January 6th. Anyway, here's Lauren Bobber.
No one on the outside can get in to the Capitol.
It is only staffers and and members of Congress
who are allowed at the people's. Towels at
our nation's capital. Judge Jeanine, this
is complete bonkers that we are keeping people out
of the United States capital. There's clearly not
a threat. There was nothing that happened on March
4th. The Democrats are obsessed with conspiracy
theories and they won't let them go. We have
a border fence around the people's health with
miles of razor wire. And Speaker Pelosi wants to
keep it up. She doesn't want a southern border to
protect us from illegal aliens. You know, we have
Biden and his handlers who aren't just dropping
bombs on foreign countries. They're blowing up our
own agencies from within. And they want to render
our Immigration and Customs Enforcement useless.
And if they pass H.R. one through the Senate,
the Democrats will have millions of illegal
voters, some of them criminals, to help Democrats
keep their control. And twenty, twenty two.
Now, I genuinely don't know if anything
that she said there is true. Some of the stuff is
like three or four layers removed from reality.
If Democrats were to try to get more
undocumented immigrants into the United States,
it would have no impact on the twenty twenty
two election because undocumented immigrants
can't even register to vote. There has been
think back to the twenty twenty election
and all of their claims about dead people
voting, people voting twice, all this stuff.
They've barely even mentioned that undocumented
immigrants voted and they've not even been able
to demonstrate that a single one did. And now
she claims as if it's a foregone conclusion
that the undocumented immigrants that Joe
Biden is supposedly letting into the country
are all going to vote somehow in 2022. How do you
even register to vote if you are not a citizen of
the United States? They never have an answer to
that question and then understand the absurdity
of Lauren Bobert saying it's Democrats obsessed
with conspiracy theories. Bobert is the one
who tries to bring guns into the House and claims
the conspiracy is with the metal detectors to try
to disarm her. She started her campaign fighting
against the imaginary idea that Democrats were
trying to come in, confiscate her guns. Bobert
has previously expressed support for Kuhnen,
but said she wasn't a follower,
just that she hopes that it's true.
These people make us a laughing stock around the
world and they don't even know it. And if you were
able to convince them, they wouldn't even care.
Her followers see this stuff and they believe it
and they're proud to have her representing them.
She says, well, listen, nothing ended up happening
on March 4th. That's right. Kuhnen thought Trump
would be inaugurated on March 4th. It was never
going to happen. There was nowhere for them to
go. The Capitol was locked down. So, of course,
nothing happened. But that doesn't prove anything.
And notice, she doesn't bring up January 6th when
a very much. Q And on and meshed group of people
violently stormed the Capitol and actually
very briefly delayed the counting of the
electoral vote. This is a really common tactic
with conspiracy theorists. You deflect by saying,
why are you so obsessed with this conspiracy which
I previously promoted? You're more obsessed with
Kuhnen than the people supposedly following you.
Maybe it doesn't even exist the way Tucker
Carlson said a couple of weeks ago, saying
I couldn't even find an official Kuhnen
website. So I don't even know that it's real.
I don't see the Lauran Bobert story ending.
Well, I think the most benign possible ending
is she just loses in twenty, twenty two and
goes away. Or maybe knowing she's going to lose,
chooses not to run. The other endings are all
worse. Either she gets reelected and this type
of thing becomes a bigger piece of our elected
House and Senate, or she's involved in some insane
incident, the likes of which I wouldn't even want
to speculate on that. But I I'm not particularly
optimistic that the Lauran Bobert as an elected
official story is going to end particularly well.